بداوا التصويت في الجوله الثانيه والحاسمه
الانتخابات الرئاسه التركيه خلال ساعه وسط
منافسه محتدمه بين اردوغان
هجوم روسي وصفته اوكرانيا بالهائل باربعين
طائره مسيره يستهدف العاصمه كييف يتسبب في
مقتل شخص واصابه ثلاثه اخرين
التوصل اتفاق مبدئي بخصوصي رفع سقف الدين
الامريكي وبايدن يدعو مجلسا نواب الشيوخ
لاقراره على الفور
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا الى نشره لاهم الانباء
من العربيه يقدمها لكم ابراهيم بدر تنطلق
بعد نحو ساعه من الان الجوله الثانيه من
الانتخابات التركيه حيث تفتح مراكز
الاختراع ابوابها في تمام الثامنه صباحا
بالتوقيت المحلي وكانت نسبه المشاركه في
الانتخابات بالجوله الاولى في الرابع عشر
من مايو الجاري بلغت
88.9% داخل تركيا وتسعه واربعين فاصل
اربعه في المئه في الخارج ويحق لاكثر من
64 مليون تركي التصويت فيما يقرب من
192 الف مركز اقتران
[موسيقى]
تحالف المعارضه الذي التف حولك الجدار
اوغلو رغم خلافاته الكبيره معه وجد نفسه
في جوله الانتخابات الرئاسيه الاولى خاسرا
للاغلبيه البرلمانيه وقاب قوسين من خساره
الرئاسه مع هذه الخسائر غير المتوقعه فقد
تحالفه حماسته واصيب في مقتل فعلى كمال
كالجدار اوغلو وتحالفه ان يستدرك فارق
الخمسه في المئه من الاصوات كلش دار اوغلو
حازه
44.9% من اصوات الناخبين في الجوله الاولى
بواقع اكثر من 24 مليون ناخب لكن الفارق
بينه وبين اردوغان كان قرابه المليوني صوت
لكن ما شكل عنصرا مفاجئا هو تقدمه على
اردوغان في كبرى المدن التركيه اهمها
اسطنبول والعاصمه انقره وازمير وديار بكر
واضنه ومرسين وانطاليا وفي المدن والمناطق
الساحليه عامه على بحري ايجا المتوسط في
مدينه انقره رجحت كفه الارقام لكل جدار
اوغلو فتفوق فيها باكثر من 47% اما في
اسطنبول المدينه الحاسمه فكانت حظوظه ايضا
اكبر من غريمه بواقع
48.6% من الاصوات لكن حظوظه لم تكن بدرجه
نفسها في مناطق الزلزال الذي حاولت
المعارضه استخدامه كورقه للضغط على
اردوغان فكانت النتائج لصالح اردوغان اعلى
بكثير كلش جدار اوغلو حصل فيها تاي على
نسبه مقاربه لاردوغان ثمانيه واربعون.
واحد بالمئه بفارق 481 صوتا اما في غازي
عنتاب فحاز
34.6% وفي قهرمان مرعش نال
22.2% من الاصوات
مرشح المعارضه اعتمد في حملته الانتخابيه
على ترحيل برنامج شامل ووعود بتحسين
النظام الديمقراطي بما في ذلك العوده الى
النظام البرلماني وطرد اللاجئين وفي جوله
الاعاده حرص على تغيير لهجته الانتخابيه
الى لهجه قادره على استماله الناخبين
القوميين وانصاره وكذلك المترددين لكنه لم
ينسى ورقته الرابحه الاكراد التي عززت
حضوره وصوتت لصالحه خلال مختلف المحطات
الانتخابيه واعطته هذه المره 20% من
الاصوات الناخبه
ارتفعت عائدات السياحه في تركيا على مدى
الاعوام الماضيه لتحقق مكاسب خياليه
للاقتصاد التركي رغم الانتكاس المؤقته
التي اصابت القطاع نتيجه الزلزال المدمر
الذي ضرب جنوبي البلاد للرئيس الحالي يد
في تحويل اسطنبول وتركيا الى وجهه سياحيه
عالميه نتابع
هادئه بتاتا تعج بالسياح كل اشهر السنه
وصلت عائدات السياحه قطع السياحه في تركيا
الى ثمانيه مليارات دولار حقق هذا الرقم ب
8.7 في الربع الاول فقط من عام 2023 يرجع
المحللين الفضل لرجب طيب اردوغان الرئيس
الحالي من خلال عده اجراءات
تسهيليه سمحت بارتفاع هذه النسبه من اهمها
رفع التاشيره او الفيزا بين تركيا ودول
اخرى فكيف وهل سيرد اصحاب هذه المطاعم
وهذه الفنادق والمحال التجاريه الفضله
لاردوغان باعاده انتخابه خاصه بانه قطاع
او وزاره السياحه تعتزم ان تصل عائداتها
الى 100 مليار دولار بعام
2028 مرحبا من وين جايين على اسط السعوديه
الرياض من السعوديه الرياض كم مره زرت
اسطنبول تقريبا بالعكس اشوف انه
اول مره اول مره ايمت زرتها لاسطنبول 2015
شو التغير اللي بين زيارتك ب 2015 و2023
احسن طورت بالنسبه للسياحه تطورت طورت
مشاكل كثير يعني من ناحيه اساليب الناس من
ناحيه امور الناس كل شيء الى الافضل يعني
مو مثل الاول انت الزياره الاولى شو
انطباعك انطباعي كويس يعني اني اجي يعني
من الكلام اللي اسمه من اصحابي انها كويسه
وكذا فقررت اني اجمعهم
وما شاء الله تبارك الرحمن يعني من ناحيه
اجواء من ناحيه
تمشيات من ناحيه العالم وتجمعات يعني
كويسه ما شاء الله الان لانه فتره الربيع
الجو جميل عندهم
وفي مناطق حلوه طبيعيه
وكمان السياحه عندهم جميله بالنسبه
للاسعار شو رايك بالاسعار بتلاقيها مرتفعه
ولا افضل من بلدان اخرى انا اول مره
سمعت انه زادت الاسعار يعني قبل سنه ممكن
ما كانت زي كذا بس انه برضه بالنسبه لو
تعتبر رخيصه يعني عادي
[موسيقى]
افاد عمده مدينه كيا فيتالي كليتشكو بمقتل
مدني واصابه امراه بجروح في العاصمه
الاوكرانيه جراء هجوم روسي وصفه بالهائل
باستخدام اكثر من اربعين طائره مسيره سهله
المدينه واشار مسؤولون الى ان الدفاعات
الجويه في كييف اسقطت اكثر من اربعين
طائره مسيره متجهه الى المدينه سقطت واحده
منها بالقرب من محطه وقود وقد ناشد عمده
المدينه سكان العاصمه البقاء في الملاج
لن يحدث بكبسه زر او بقطع شريط احمر لكن
بدء الهجوم الاوكراني المضاد او عدمه بات
موضع تساؤلات مع ظهور الدلائل المفترضه اي
دخول فصل الربيع والجفاف الاراضي الموحده
التي عرقلت سابقا حركه المركبات الثقيله
اوكرانيا مستعده لشن الهجوم المضاد ويمكن
ان يبدا غدا او بعد اسبوع
ورغم غياب اي تحركات دراماتيكيه للقوات
الاوكرانيه حتى اللحظه الا ان الهجوم
المضاد قد يكون جاريا بالفعل بهدوء في ظل
عمليه متواصله على طول حدود ممتده ل 1500
كيلومتر
التدمير
المكثفات العدو روسيا هو ايضا هجوم مضاد
[موسيقى]
دروسيه تكررت مؤخرا مع استهداف صواريخ
اوكرانيه لمناطق مختلفه في بيلجورو جنوب
روسيا بينها شبه القوات الاوكرانيه استغلت
كذلك وجود ادنى مستويات الرطوبه التربه في
زابوريجيا وخيرسون فمحاولتها مستمره
لاسترجاع مدينه
وذلك سعيا منها لكسر الجسر البري بين
روسيا وشبه جزيره القرم ما يؤدي الى قطع
خطوط الامداد اللوجستيه الحيويه الحمله
الاوكرانيه تدفع كذلك خط المواجهه للخلف
من اماكن مثل اوريخيف وهي بلده تبعد حوالي
خمسه كيلو مترات من خطوط المواجهه
انفجارات واعمده دخان ضغط على المشهد في
ماريوبولا الواقعه في دوناتسك والتي تم
استهدافها بصواريخها بعيده المدى اما
المعركه المستميته في باخمه المدمره خفت
وقعها بل انتهت فعليا وفقا نيويورك تايمز
علما بان امال موسكو كانت عريضه في
استثمار الاستيلاء على نقطه انطلاق نحو
مدن كبرى
ظروف شبه مثاليه للهجوم المنتظر التربه
الجافه والطقس الملائم لتحرك الدبابات بعض
عوامله يغذيها تلقي كييف لشحنات ضخمه من
الاسلحه وقوات روسيه مرهقه ومشتته
الانتباه بعد قتال مطول في باخموت
قلت هنا مليار نائبه وزير الدفاع
الاوكراني في بيان ان القوات الروسيه خففت
من وتيره هجماتها على مدينه بخموت
المحاصره شرق اوكرانيا بهدف اعاده تنظيم
صفوفها وتعزيز قدراتها القتاليه واضافت
المسؤول الاوكرانيه بان القوات الروسيه
باتت تقصف الضواحي والطرق المؤديه الى
ضخمه من جانبه اكد ميخائيل بودلاك مساعد
الرئيس الاوكراني على ان العمليات الاوليه
مثل تدمير خطوط الامداد الروسي او تفجير
مستودعات بدات بالفعل تمهيدا لشن الهجوم
الاوكرانيه المضاد
اكدت الخارجيه الايرانيه ان الهدف من
انتقادات الرئيس
الاوكرانيسك المستمره لها والاتهامات
بانها تدعم روسيا عسكريا هو الحصول على
اسلحه اضافيه من الغرب نافيه تقديم اي دعم
عسكري لموسكو
حرب الاتهامات المتبادله تشتعل من جديد
بين الرئيس الاوكراني
اتهامات لطالما تمحورت حول دعم ايران
لروسيا بالمسيرات التي يتم استخدامها ضد
اوكرانيا موقف جديد من الجانب الايراني
جاءك رد على تحرك زينسكي الاخير الذي دعا
فيه الشعب الايراني الى ممارسه ضغوط على
حكومته للتوقف عن امداد موسكو بالطائرات
المسيره حيث انتقدت من خلاله طهران الرئيس
الاوكراني ووصف التحركاته بالاستعراض
السياسي المصحوب بالدعاءات لا اساس لها
وهنا اكدت ايران ان زليسكي ومع اقتراب
موعد الهجوم المضاد الذي يمكن ان تنفذه
كييف على مراحل يسعى الى تحصيل اكبر قدر
ممكن من الاسلحه والمساعدات الماليه من
الدول الغربيه بتكثيفه الاتهامات لايران
وكانت واشنطن ودول غربيه فرضت عقوبات على
ايران لدعمها الجانب الروسي بمسيارات
استخدمت لضرب اهداف في كييف قالت ايران
حينها انها ارسلتها لروسيا قبل الحرب فيما
لم تؤكد موسكو ذلك
الموقف الايراني يتزامن مع استمرار
انتقادات الرئيس الاوكراني لدعم طهران
المتواصل لروسيا بمسيارات انتحاريه تستهدف
مناطق سكنيه في بلاده
نشرتنا مستمره وتتابعون فيها بعض الفاصل
هي
مهرجان كان لهذا العام يتحول الى منبر
للتنديد بالحكومه الفرنسيه بسبب موقفها من
الاحتجاجات وقانون التقاعد
انا بكم من جديد بعد اعلان رئيس مجلس
النواب الامريكي كذا مكارتي التوصل الى
الاتفاق مبدئي بشان سقف الدين حث الرئيس
جو بايدن مجلسي النواب الشيوخ على تمرير
اتفاق سقف الدين الامريكي على الفور مشيرا
الى ان العمل جاري لوضع اللمسات النهائيه
على النص التشريعي للاتفاق وعرضه على
مجلسي النواب والشيوخ واوضح بايدن ان
اتفاق سقف الدين الامريكي يمثل توافقا
وخطوه مهمه للامام كما سيمنع سقف الدين
تخلفا كارثيا عن السبب
وكان رئيس مجلس النواب الامريكي الجمهوري
كيف مكارتي اعلن التوصل اتفاق مبدئي مع
البيت الابيض مشيرا الى ان الاتفاق يتضمن
تخفيضا تاريخيا في حجم الانفاق واصلاحات
لابعاد الناس عن الفقر موضحا ان مشروع
القانون سيتم التصويت عليه في الكونجرس
يوم الاربعاء المقبل
تحدثت الى الرئيس مرتين بعد اسبوعين من
المفاوضات توصلنا الى اتفاق من حيث المبدا
لكن لا يزال هنالك الكثير من العمل اعتقد
ان هذا الاتفاق مرضا للامريكيين يتضمن
تخفيضا تاريخيا في حجم الانفاق واصلاحات
لابعاد الناس عن الفقر ولا يكون هناك
ضرائب ولا برامج حكوميه سيتم مراجعه
الاتفاق ومناقشته مع الرئيس بايدن ومن
المتوقع التصويت على مشروع القانون
الاربعاء المقبل
[موسيقى]
دعت السعوديه الولايات والولايات المتحده
الجيش السوداني وقوات الدعم السري الى
مواصله النقاش للتوصلي لاتفاقهم بشان
تمديد وقف اطلاق النار الذي سينتهي في
التاسع والعشرين من شهر مايو لانه سيسهل
ايصال المساعدات الانسانيه التي يحتاجها
الشعب السوداني واكدت على ضروره تقيد
الطرفين بالتزامهما بموجب وقف اطلاق النار
قصير الامد من اجل حمايه المدنيين في
السودان
وكانت قوات الدعم السريع عبت رغبتها في
مواصله مباحثات تجديد اتفاق وقف اطلاق
النار في السودان بينما تجددت الاشتباكات
بين الجيش وقوات الدعم في العاصمه الخرطوم
رغم الهدنه بين الطرفين وكان الجيش
السوداني تمكن من صد هجوم لقوات الدعم
السريع على مدينه الفاشر في دارفور بحسب
ما افادت به مصادر العربيه واضافت مصادر
بان الجيش تمكن ايضا من فك الحصار الذي
فرضته قوه الدعم السريع على زلنجي لمده
اسبوع
حذرت شركه مايكروسوفت قبل ايام من ان
قراصنه صينينا مدعومين من الحكومه اضروا
بالبنيه التحتيه السيبرانيه الامريكيه
الحيويه تحذير اكدته الولايات المتحده
وحلفائها من الدول والشركات
الهادئ لا يحدث عند استعراض الصين
صواريخها البالستيه فقط ولا يقف عند اسطول
البحريه الامريكي المهيب بل هي حملات
القرصنه المنهجه التهديد الاخطر والاقرب
ربما لتفجير ازمه مستقبليه
بدات قصه الاختراق الصيني لاهم قاعده
امريكيه في غرب الهادئ جوان وللبنيه
التحتيه داخل الولايات المتحده باخذ حيز
كبير في الاعلام الغربي منذ ايام
مجموعه القراصنه المدعومين من الحكومه
الصينيه والمعروفه بتخصصها في جمع
المعلومات كما تدعي الاستخبارات الامريكيه
في تقريرها كانت وراء الهجوم لم تكن تلك
المحاوله الاولى للمجموعه لكنها كانت
نوعيه وتصعيديه لحد كبير والغريب ان
مايكروسوفت هي من فجرت القصه ليتوالا
بعدها ظهور مسؤولين من وكاله الامن القومي
والامن السيبراني والبحريه الامريكيه
للتاكيد على ان لا يزال قائما دون ذكر اي
تفاصيل غير ان معلومه واحده افادت بان
العمليه تتطابق مع طريقه معروفه باختراق
الشبكات تصل للحواف فقط لابقائها غير
مكتشفه لسنوات وبعدها تفعل في الوقت
المناسب
عمليه مماثله قادره على القضاء على
الشبكات واحداث خلل في الاليات العسكريه
وهو ما ذكره التحالف الاستخبارتي العيون
الخمس تشريف النفي الصيني للاتهام
الامريكي لم يكن مستغربا ووصف بانه حمله
تضليل جماعيه تقودها امريكا لخدمه اجندتها
الجيوسياسيه اما السر في اختيار
مايكروسوفت لنشر القصه فاعتبره محللون
دعوه مفتوحه لشركات القطاع الخاص لحمايه
الشبكات والبنيه التحتيه العمود الفقري
الحقيقي للامن القومي الامريكي كرم حناوي
العربيه
فقدان التنوع البيولوجي النجم عن التصنيع
البشري احد اخطر التحديات التي تتربص
البشريه خلال العقود المقبله حيث حضرت
احدث الدراسات من خطر احتمال انقراض عشرات
الاف الانواع من الحيوانات على الارض ما
يؤثر على عمل النظم البيئيه وانتشار
الامراض
ابواب مملكتهم ليست مصابه فالحروب
والتغيرات المناخيه اعاست في بيئتهم ايضا
خرابا حتى لم تعد قادره على احتواء
المخلوقات الحيه التي تقطنها غير ان موت
هذه الحيوانات او هربها من موطنها الاصلي
يقلل من التنوع الحيوي للمنطقه ما يؤدي
للتضرر سلسله متكامله تبدا بفقدان وتدهور
الغابات وتلوث المياه والهواء مرورا بتغير
المناخ وصولا الى تهديد صحه الانسان ففي
بحث هو الاوسع عبر التاريخ كشفت جامعه
كوينز بالفاس في ايرلندا ان
28% من الحياه على الارض مهدده حاليا
بالانقراض ودقت ناقوس الخطر فيما يخص
تراجع اعداد اكثر من 70 الف نوعا من
الحيوانات في كل انحاء العالم اي ما يعادل
48% منها
اما اهم اسباب فقدان المواطن الطبيعيه
للتنوع الاحيائي فتعود الى استفحال ظواهر
الاحتباس الحراري مترافقه مع ارتفاع نسب
الغازات الدفيئه بفعل التلوث الصناعي اي
ما تخلفه المصانع والمعامل من نفايات
والسموم في الماء والهواء والتربه
فيما يبقى التاثير الاخطر لانتشار الحروب
واستخدام الاسلحه الفتاكه والمحرمه دوليا
التي تلوث التربه بالاشعاعات لعقود طويله
وفي وقت تتفلت الحلول من الايدي طرحت
الدراسه نفسها برامج واستراتيجيات للحد او
التخفيف من خسائر التنوع الحيويه بينها
حمايه المناطق البريه والمحميات الطبيعيه
والحد من المتاجره غير المشروعه
بالحيوانات والنباتات ومكافحه الصيد
الجائر والتلويث الطبيعه وتسريع التحول
نحو الطاقه المتجدده
تسبب صرصور في سنفار امنيه بعدما اثار ذو
الرواد مقهى بشارع ديزنجو في قلب تل ابيب
باسرائيل تعرض على اثره شخصان لاصابات
طفيفه جراء تحطم الزجاج اثناء محاولتهما
الفرار من موقع الحادث حاله الفوضى اندلعت
في المقهى بعد رؤيه صرصور الذي اثار فزع
امراه اسقطت منضضتها ارضا ليعتقد الرواد
ان هناك مشكله امنيه ويستدعو الشرطه على
الفور
فازت المخرجه جوستين بجائزه السعفه
الذهبيه عن فيلمها انا
السينمائيه الفرنسيه اخترت توجيه رساله
سياسيه من منبر مهرجان كان نددت فيها بشده
بقمر الحكومه الفرنسيه الصادم للتحركات
الاحتجاجيه المناهضه لاصلاح قانون التقاعد
في البلاد نتابع اختتام مهرجان كان
السينمائي برسائل سياسيه
الفائزه بجائزه السعفه الذهبيه
تنتقد الحكومه الفرنسيه من منبر مهرجان
كان
وتردد بمقاربه باريس ملف التقاعد والقمع
الذي استخدم ضد المتظاهرين
مبديه اعتقادها بان السلطه سعت الى تحطيم
الاستثناء الثقافي الفرنسي وزيره الثقافه
الفرنسيه وصفت خطابه رياب الظالم
واكدت ان الفيلم الفائز ما كان ليرى النور
لولا تمويل الحكومه الفرنسيه للاعمال
السينمائيه
في نهايه
بدء التصويت في الجوله الثانيه والحاسمه
من انتخابات الرئاسه التركيه خلال نصف
ساعه من الان وصله منافسه محتدمه بين
اردوغان وكليتش دار
هجوم روسي بالمسيرات وصفته اوكرانيا
بالهائل استهدف العاصمه وكيف تقول انها
اسقطت اكثر من اربعين منها
التوصل لاتفاق مبدئيا بخصوص رفع سقف الدين
الامريكي وبايدن يدعو مجلسي النواب
والشيوخ لاقراره على الفور
نهايه النشر الى اللقاء عند المتصف
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على يوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات